let's get to Sunday's MTV Video Music
Awards Rachel Smith is outside MTV
headquarters in Times Square Miss Rachel
what's up
hey there Michelle yeah a lot of behind
the scenes magic going on right here and
over at the Prudential Center in New
Jersey now E.T is the only show
backstage at the VMAs and here's a
little taste of what you can expect
[Music]
cool NAB the most wins we're thinking
Harry Styles Doja cats and Jack Harlow
are you ready are you ready
yes I am they each have eight knobs and
you'll be seeing a lot of Jack he's one
of three VMA hosts it's still some tea
let the performance speak we let the
music speak joining him LL Cool J a lot
of excitement
um artists being celebrated and Nicki
Minaj who will receive this year's video
Vanguard award there are rumors Johnny
Depp could make a surprise appearance as
a moon person we'll have to wait and see
on that but what we do know Johnny was
considered to present the global icon
award to the Red Hot Chili Peppers but
ET has learned the band decided instead
to have actors Cheech and Chong do the
honors
[Music]
and we're getting the first look at the
show's seating carts that's lizzo next
to Brazilian singer Anita they're both
hitting the stage Lil Mouse is seated
next to Jack Harlow they say he was
Superstar now down I guess I am another
big moment Kane Brown's making MTV
history I'm so pumped that I get to be a
first
the first solo male country artist to
ever perform is also nominated it feels
amazing to be performing on the iconic
MTV stage uh just because I've always
watched it especially being a first as a
country artist is amazing I've always
been the guy that kind of branches
different genres of music King song
Brand is up for song of the summer if I
did win the moon person I would
definitely put him on my gaming desk so
I could play with him on stream also
hitting the MTV stage Snoop you're gonna
perform with Eminem this weekend tell me
about that me and uh Marshall Mathis we
collaborated on a record that we wanted
to do for many years and we did an
amazing video
the video got nominated and then MTV
wanted us to perform so we'll be
actually performing in a different world
but actually there
[Music]